yeah I think that one of the like when I
when I first watched that Kanye
interview did it was almost two years
ago now maybe a year and a half out of
here that was like where I was like oh
this guy's this guy's got it like this
this because you got a great yay
interview it was luck and shout out to
what whack helped make that hack 100s
that's whack 100 he's the secret sauce
behind that relationship yeah I love
whack's a great guy man he doesn't get
the credit he deserves I I always I've
been friends with whack for over 10
years and I always say he's one of the
smartest dudes in the game I know
sometimes wackets on clubhouse and whack
is going to whack or whack is very
brilliant yeah he's brilliant yeah
people don't give him the credit and and
the other thing I love and he told the
story recently and and I want to say
that like when when ice open my studio
Hollywood unlocked Studios the idea at
first was very focused on a space for
creators to create a peer space type
situation yeah like that and then uh the
day it opened I was sitting in my
kitchen with um blue who was my former
co-host on the podcast I was like and
damage I was like how we gonna
I think damage was there I know blue was
there because I was like how we gonna
Market how am I gonna Market this I
don't know how to really do it like I've
never I just built the Space now how do
we Market it phone rings swag literally
yo yo yo nephew is your your studio but
I'm like yeah he's like um yeah I got
somebody that want to rent it it's okay
let me talk to him so he puts Kanye on
the phone wow hello he's like yo this is
yay you know uh nice to meet you you
know I got and I'm like sitting there I
put him on speakerphone and we're like
gagging like what the [__] you know and
he's like I want to use my cousin pocket
when can you come to dinner where can
you pull up I said when you want me an
hour I said okay I went to Craig's whack
this is the thing that again doesn't
really happen because people who plug
people in want to be the gatekeeper of
that relationship and eat off of that
too forever
whack came in he sat me down next to
Kanye and he sat all the way across the
room completely let Mia sit there and
Vibe for about four hours and really
talk and listen to music and he let me
hear all the you know different stuff he
had coming out for Donna too and then we
started vibing and I started just
telling him who I was when I was about
we clicked and then um the next day we
he called and said what you doing now so
I got Floyd Mayweather and Evan Ross at
my studio we chilling and they look at
the space he was like you want to have a
dinner tonight I got Madonna ask for if
he want to come and then we had this
epic ass dinner and then he got in a
fight with the I think I saw the
pictures from that night it was like you
and Madonna was there was Antonio Brown
there yeah yeah and then um
he got in a fight with the paparazzi
that night caught me the next day and
said well wax said like you know you can
help me with this that you have a
platform that I apologize I wasn't aware
and yeah talking about Hollywood a lot
he's okay let me know if I can come by I
said okay who'll come by you know we'll
talk about it whenever so I sent to that
address and I went into a meeting and
I'm in a meeting with this woman and her
artist and we're sitting there chilling
and then the ding dong at the doorbell
my Johnny my video director went open
the door and it was Kanye it's [__]
crazy he was like let's do it now the
interview now no prep no yeah we did it
it's crazy too because like then
obviously you're kind of put in charge
of his what what was your title I was
head of media right for a very short
stint seven months seven months but I
left on my own amazing uh thing to throw
on the resume uh yeah I didn't think it
would be I mean
I I want to kind of because you're you
could probably be like the best PR guy
in the game if you wanted to be yeah
a situation like Yay if you're his PR
person how do you how do you bring them
back how do you uncancel the situation
let's say he's level-headed he got
through whatever this weird like Hitler
White lives matter [__] was going like
what do you what's the advice you give
if he calls you tomorrow and says I got
a guy well I called him to give him the
advice I'm gonna tell you what I was
gonna give him right now and I haven't
told nobody this and I and I didn't give
it to him because of his response to me
when I called I'm a very genuine
authentic person
um I don't play games I'm not gonna like
sell nobody on nothing even if he wasn't
in his right mind if he at least wanted
to stop the bleeding to be able to focus
on finding his right mind to then get
back to the center what I would have
done
uh and let's be clear that interview I
did with him actually brought him closer
back to the center because the culture
forgave him we followed up with a media
brunch with all the top black
storytellers from all walks of media I
mean we did a Facebook I mean we did I
mean he was centered he chose to be on
centered again what I called him to tell
him that I didn't get to tell him
directly because he wanted me to put in
a text I don't text because he would
have probably screenshotted it and then
posted it and been like which is why I
chose not to text right what he could
have done because let's be very clear
what Yae was saying
the topic that he was talking about was
a real topic the power construct of the
industry the power
um the lack of resources the
manipulation there's a lot of gems in
that drink Champs interview that get
overlooked because of the other [__] he
said the delivery was just completely
[__] wrong for sure you know Jewish
people and black people
Mexicans all different groups have had
very challenging experiences in their
communities the Holocaust slavery why do
we need a politic pain like everybody's
been through their [__] right and I've
been have relationships with Jewish
people who've brought me in and I felt a
sense of community where they were all
equally interested in my success in
pulling together resources unlike how
sometimes my community does so what he
was saying in terms of you know
different Power constructs and you know
opportunities and who owns what is true
how they did that I I would say we have
as a black community have to own some of
that because we choose to politic
positions oh I'm over here running this
so I'm not gonna let these [__] and
I'm gonna let these [__] in or I'm
gonna grandfather my homies in but not
put this [__] on who's on like there's
so many people who could have done more
for me when they saw me coming because
they saw the potential but they didn't
[__] with me I'm gay I'm this I'm loud
I'm whatever [__] them all now I got
more money than him so when I look at
with yay I said what he was doing I
agreed with the topic that he was
addressing but I didn't agree with the
delivery what I told him what I would
have told him from Dubai could have did
was during the time when he was burning
out with all lives matter Candice Owens
all that and doing all every random
[__] interview first thing I would
have said is you need to move very
strategic I would have
backed up from it all I would have hired
a production company I would have turned
this whole experience into a documentary
I would have pulled in Kyrie Irving I
would have examined America and race
relations in the world based on his
activity I would have made it look like
I did it on purpose on purpose I would
have here's this piece of art I would
have flipped it all up very artistically
on its head I would have interviewed
people from the Jewish group I would
have pulled everybody in Candace Owens
the founder of black lives matter I
would have put everybody into this very
um inclusive work of art who could have
made us all take a step back to examine
how he was destroyed when he said what
he said when we have people who are
white climbing up the capitol trying to
kill the vice president overturn an
election who are still not in prison you
know there's a real conversation to be
had and and they still have their bank
accounts and they still have their bank
accounts you know since when does a bank
say come get your money out because the
news is saying well Wells Fargo probably
told him that because they stole Wendy
Williams money I don't know if his Wells
Fargo Chase but they I think it was
Chase they've all done [__] [__] you
know Wells Fargo taking all of Wendy
Williams money because they thought she
was incompetent there was no court
document or nothing that said that you
know when do you say pull out all your
money you do that because you want to be
in the news because you want people to
go and look at your products and
services they used him and he allowed
himself to be used what I'm really big
on is controlling your narrative how do
you
create a conversation that may make the
whole world blow up but when you shake
it out it's it it it it it it it shapes
into this work of art that actually
makes people go back and start having
critical thinking he wasn't able to
really do that because I think he was
too emotionally involved in it you know
and he had some really good people
around him that could have helped him
and then unfortunately he wanted me to
text him that
um but I I said I'm not going to text
you no problem because I I don't I told
him I said I don't want you to pay me
for this idea I don't want to be
involved with this idea I don't want any
credit for this idea I don't want any
public association with this idea that's
what I was going to tell him I just want
you to be able to stop the noise of what
you've created now with this whole
conversation around a topic that is a
real topic we could have elevated
through our relationship but that you
chose to go nuclear on because you had a
point to prove and now you're being sued
by everybody and you're going to lose
everything and you're going to feel like
you're right because ultimately if he
runs for president now and Trump runs
for president and he loses he can say
the only reason Trump won is because
White lives matter he can say that but
by this point you've turned the whole
world off from listening to that yeah I
feel like he kind of like um
he kind of like unintentionally hoard
himself out to the alt-right content
space to where like and I don't think it
was his intent you know what I mean but
I think that like when you go on like
certain podcasts and you talk to certain
people it's like you're you're kind of
just like
giving them all the ammunition that they
need to kind of continue to push hate on
their side while you're kind of
oblivious to that because you think that
you're like I don't it's just very he's
my favorite artist ever so it's like
well I said he's he definitely is
gaslighting the culture and he's serving
up uh white supremacy you know and it's
unfortunate because I will say this as
much as I've been critical I'm also very
much a fan I think he's one of the most
brilliant artists in the world he's
definitely a culture disruptor culture
shifter culture leader icon all that
he's all of that but all of that you can
still be flawed I think the one flaw
that yay has and I say this with love
um is that he just he he the the the
Putin and the the Hitler references is
more about kind of being that
uncheckable dictator that controls the
world as he wants to see it and not be
questioned uh but that's just not the
reality where we live in you know I
think you got to like read the room and
I I think the Hitler [__] that he was
saying was like coming from a place of
like Jesus loves everybody Jesus
forgives everybody I love Hitler I love
Jews but I just felt like
yeah sometimes you got to read the room
man you know it's Jesus May forgive
everybody but that don't mean you ain't
going that I mean you ain't gonna go to
hell and burn to death you know what I'm
saying yeah it was just unfortunate to
see you like you said it's like we've
never this is a one-of-one situation
probably the most culturally important
person that hip-hop has probably ever
had he's moved fashion musically he's
that guy and it just kind of like four
months and it's just evaporated it's
kind of crazy crazy thing is I think he
could come back I think he could too you
know I think he'd come back but like he
has
you know I I will say it was a it was an
honor to be able to be there my whole
goal was not to be like known for being
his head of me and all that that's great
that people know that he put me in a
room with the president of Gap with the
presidents of Adidas with the leaders of
these organizations who
um at the time were spending no money in
marketing no money in our communities to
seed programs and so as head of media I
I found my way into conversations with
people to say if he makes you three
billion dollars can you not put five
percent towards programs in our
community and they were on board with
this they were like they were hungry for
ideas he just needed a green light he
never did so the frustrating part was
the idea of what we wanted to do was we
had a billion dollar commitment outside
of the U.S to raise to to get this money
to buy all these media conglomerates to
be able to put them under one house that
I would sit on and help to really shape
narrative for the culture
and on top of that be able to get these
Fortune 500 Brands to be able to spend
hundreds of millions of dollars pouring
back into our community that's the
privilege that I thought I had there and
then it became a circus and and when I
realized like I'm a very strategic
person once I saw like this is not what
it is I don't want to spend the time I
have on earth like playing around like I
want to leave an imprint a legacy do you
think he had a lot of yes people around
him and you're obviously not a yes man
so like being in that short amount of
time would you say that his inner circle
was pretty just kind of like no I won't
say that I'll say that he had a lot of
really good
people
who did the work that needed to be done
and when it was time to say no would say
no but it was typically through me which
made me the bad guy right and and when
they said no they said it in ways that
would get him to understand there's a
need to pause and then I would come in
with the no right why and I think
strategically we all worked well
together like everybody had their Lane I
wasn't management I was you know I but I
became a let's how do we put out this
fire yeah what's your advice on how we
do this and he never wanted to do it so
you know it wasn't that I didn't have
all the answers or that he didn't need
all the answers I just think that he
wanted to do things his way and now he
can look at his world and see that that
probably didn't work out in his favor
but I won't say it was because everybody
around him was bad he had really good
people I mean he had the best
um divorce attorney the only one I think
that could have beat Kim Kardashian at
least leveled it out for him he had the
best um other attorneys the Gap person I
mean everybody around him was they were
good people but you know he chose what
he chose and here we are yeah